foreign
[Music]
accounting for the non-financial
executive then it provides a thorough
foundation and Finance and Accounting
for executives that are not Financial
specialists it's essential to have an
understanding of Finance and Accounting
because it is the way companies keep
score
there are many people who rise to
positions of great responsibility
without feeling great confidence in
their understanding of the subjects of
Finance and Accounting at point you just
need a solid understanding of the key
Concepts Frameworks and fundamentals in
accounting and finance to make the best
decisions fanfi gave me a better
understanding of the stories that I hear
our business telling to the markets but
also how I hear our Executives talking
about investment priorities within the
business how a company decides on a
dividend understand the relationship
between balance sheet and income
statement and cash flow it's learning a
language and that language allows you to
better analyze what the constraints are
what the opportunities are and gives you
better information to make that business
decision
getting to learn how do you create value
across different Industries was pretty
fascinating and then to hear from the
actual managers of those companies
within the room was very valuable better
understanding can be critical to better
corporate strategy and of course better
corporate strategy is essential to being
a winner
with this knowledge I now have the tools
I now feel better equipped in a both on
a personal basis to make better
financial decisions in my life but also
better financial decisions in my
business and for my customers people are
going to walk away with more competence
and more confidence Executives will make
a better contribution to the
organization when they go back
[Music]